hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and in this video i will
explain why
deku is now able to use multiple quirks
and i will also explain what those new
quirks are
and how they work since deku's ability
to manifest
multiple quirks has finally been
revealed in the anime with the sudden
introduction of black whip
i thought that this would be the perfect
time to make a quick video
and clear up all of the confusion so
let's get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
here on the channel and you want to see
more please leave a like and comment
it only takes a second and it's a
totally free way to support the channel
and of course if you're new to anime
outro or maybe you watch our videos but
you haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a ton of our videos even if you
are subscribed it's just how youtube
works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror now even though the
information about blackwhip and deku's
new quirks is new to anime only fans
manga readers have known about it for
like over 3 years
this means that not only do we know
about black whip but as of the making of
this video we also know
4 other quirks that deku is eventually
going to be able to use
in this video i will explain what all of
these quirks are
and how they work but i won't get into
the details about the plot of the story
in case you're an anime only so if
you're cool with learning about the
quirks themselves and how they work
without any major plot spoilers
this is the video for you but if you
don't want
any spoilers at all beyond the anime
then proceed with caution you have been
warned
so as we know the quirk one for all was
created accidentally
when the villain all for one decided to
give his seemingly quirkless brother
a stockpiling quirk but all for one's
younger brother did already have a quirk
that no one knew about because it was
pretty much
inactive this quirk had only one
function and that was the ability to
transfer itself from one person to
another
initially this was basically useless but
after all for one gave his brother a
quirk that stockpile's power
that stockpiling quirk combined with the
transferring quirk in order to create
what we know
today as one for all as it turns out all
for one's younger brother was completely
against his brother's villainous plans
and so once he was able to use one for
all he started actively opposing his
brother
unfortunately all for one's brother was
not strong enough to defeat all for one
and he eventually died but before he
died he managed to
pass the quirk one for all on to a
successor
and this transferring continued
generation after generation until the
quirk finally ended up with
deku and deku is of course the ninth and
current
one for all user since one of the two
quirks that were used to create one for
all was a quirk that stockpiles power
as one for all was passed on from user
to user
it actually became stronger because it
keeps accumulating
more power one for all is growing and
evolving over time in episode 98 of the
anime and chapter 212 of the manga
deku finds himself inside that strange
vestige world
after the sudden and unexpected
activation of a new power within him
a power that we eventually learn is a
quirk called black whip
the original owner of this quirk appears
before deku
and he explains to daku that he is not
alone
the vestiges of the previous users of
one for all are still
living inside of one for all moreover
the core of one for all is getting
larger and the quirk factors of all of
the previous users have been mixed
into that core this may sound a bit
confusing so i'll try to clear it up as
much as possible
basically one for all score retains the
quirk factor
of each previous user and it also
retains some aspect of the user's
consciousness
the previous users themselves are all
dead except for all might of course
but some part of their consciousness
remained
inside one for all these consciousnesses
are what we refer to as
vestiges and they are able to directly
communicate with deku the current
one for all user when certain conditions
are met
now about the quirks before deku no
other one for all user had access to the
previous user's quirks
so for example all might could not use
nana's quirk or any other quirk aside
from one for all itself
but for some reason deku is the first
user who has been able to unlock
the quirk factors of the previous users
which allows them to manifest
their quirks now you might be asking
yourself why is daku
so special the long answer is that one
for all has been getting stronger with
each new user its core has been
expanding
and deku just happens to be the one who
inherited the quirk at a critical time
in its continuing evolution up until
this point one for all was still
changing and growing but now deku is the
first user who has the potential
to truly complete one for all the short
answer
is protagonist powers the first new
quirk that deku is able to activate
is of course black whip this quirk
allows its user to generate black
tendrils from their body and use these
tendrils to either attack an opponent
restrain an opponent or increase the
versatility of the user's
own movements black whip is an extremely
useful quirk
and it appears to be powered by strong
emotions such as anger
this means that the angrier the user
becomes while still maintaining control
of his senses
the stronger the quirk will become but
the user must learn to control
and channel that anger properly by
maintaining a pure heart
otherwise the user could lose control of
the court black whip suddenly activated
inside of deku during the showdown
against
class 1b just as deku thought i'll
capture that guy
while chasing nato monoma this strong
urge to capture monoma that deku
felt in that moment subconsciously
triggered the activation of black whip
because this was the best quirk for that
job
deku was caught off guard by black
whip's sudden activation
and at first he was unable to control it
he needed to work together with ochako
and shinso
in order to restrain the quirk part of
the reason why deku struggled to control
the quirk is the fact that black whip
is much stronger now than it had been
originally black whip is now being
powered by the growing strength of one
for all itself
so it is much stronger now than it was
when it was possessed by its
original user and the same goes for the
other five quirks that deku
is going to manifest and speaking of
those five
other quirks what are they and how do
they work
just like deku all might is quirkless so
deku won't be inheriting a quirk from
him
but almight's former master nana shimura
possessed a quirk
called float which allowed her to
levitate in the air
deku will learn this high flying quirk
in the near future
another quirk that deku will be learning
is smokescreen
which allows its user to expel a thick
cloud of smoke from their body
the smoke can be spread to cover a wide
area
and this serves as a way to obscure the
vision of your opponents
allowing you to hide from them and
either catch them by surprise or simply
escape from them
yet another quirk that deku is going to
manifest is
danger sense which allows its user to
instantly identify
imminent threats in the surrounding area
so it's basically a spidey sense
and then there's fog in a quirk that
allows its user to build up kinetic
energy
in different parts of their body and
then use that energy to release an
explosive burst of speed
and power i'm sure you can already
imagine the insane quirk combos that
deku is going to be able to use
in the future and yeah you better
believe that the upcoming fights between
dekko and the villains are going to be
absolutely
incredible now the first user of one for
all possessed
one for all itself and deku has already
been using it for a long time
this means that only one more new quirk
remains
and this final quirk belongs to the
second one for all user
the one who inherited the quirk directly
from all for one's younger brother
this is the last quirk to be revealed in
the story and unfortunately as of the
making of this video this final quirk
still hasn't appeared
but as soon as this quirk is revealed i
will make a video covering it and
explaining all of its powers and
abilities
so if you enjoy our content here at
anime uproar definitely subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you won't
miss
any of our future videos let me know
what you guys think about the evolution
of one for all do you think that one for
all is becoming too
op or are you looking forward to seeing
all the epic new quirks and quirk
combos that dekku is going to be using
finally
if you had to choose between getting one
for all or all for one
which of the two quirks would you choose
let me know down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this pokuno hero video
and you want to see more in the future
just leave a like it only takes a second
but it helps a lot
feel free to hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar a big thank you to all
of our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and
red-haired raven
these guys are absolute mad lads and
disciples
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algertol dr cortman the toasted chi rai
carlo
slickback emperor otaku spidey life
chanel tungsten tarkis baked buddhist
and cody hebert
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki cricket xp
very gucci alicia octor bonnie park
sinokami and water 10 no ted
hi sparky 65 joanne garcia fat boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pillow
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patreon exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you